the first Mirror's Edge was a painfully
flawed game but during those fleeting
moments where everything works as
intended there was nothing quite likely
few games can match it for evoking a
sense of blissful freedom it was almost
as though you could feel the wind sail
through you as you dashed and bolted and
clambered across its rooftops an air
vent water pipes it's these memories
that make me so encouraged about the
game you're looking at now Mirror's Edge
catalyst VA's long-awaited reboot of
this distinct first person parkour
adventure because here that zen-like
feeling of empowerment and momentum that
sense that you are the master of your
elements is very much still alive but
all the floors the came of the first
game they appear to be gone
chief among the emissions is the
firearms halfway through the first
message the game just sort of gave up
being what it wanted to be and hand you
a lame automatic pistol however at no
point in catalyst we are told will you
enact your second Amendment right
overcoming foes is achieved with melee
attacks driven by momentum the faster
and further you run the harder you hit
mixing melee attacks with jumps and
dashes and slides the order of the day
but you have to keep moving if you find
yourself ruling of someone from a static
standing position the fight will likely
be awkward graceless and deliberately
tedious
murs edge catus demands you move as fast
as possible in fact if you build up
enough speed of momentum eventually your
enter state where you automatically
dodge bullets the on-screen hints of
where to go next meanwhile come via
dashes of red painless speed off into
the distance it's almost as if the game
is telling you to keep half of its
directions
catalyst has also adopted an open world
mission structure much like in Grand
Theft Auto games you encounter people
across the city of glass to find out
what missions they have for you some are
main characters who present key
objectives that drive the narrative
forwards other our random people
scattered across the rooftops you know
just hanging out who offer various side
quests for gamer hinges so much on
exploration it's a no-brainer that dice
opened up the world the main mission
stick to the basics one moment you'll be
breaking into a building and hacking
into a computer terminal the next you'll
be fleeing from armed helicopters in
pursuit the side quests tend to ask you
to deliver a package or reach a certain
point in the map within a certain
timeframe the tight time constraints
place on you demand flawless freerunning
and make such challenges exhilarating on
top of this is a new feature that allows
you to create your own time trials for
other players to complete you place
markers and checkpoints across the city
and upload that route online on paper it
seems like a bullet point edition a way
for dice to shoehorn in an online
feature in practice it's utterly
absorbing stripping the game down to the
fundamental joy of fighting against the
clock by running as efficiently and
creatively as possible I suppose that
shouldn't be a surprise free running
after all has always been the
fundamental joy of this series for every
annoyance that catalyst appears to have
removed it's so encouraging to see that
dice completely understands what fans
love about the original Mirror's Edge
catalyst is due to ship on May 24 from
ps4 xbox one and pc you can head to game
sort right now for an in-depth preview
with a full breakdown of the games
you